What are the strikes against a microkernel based
design? The first strike is the border crossing
cost going between kernel and the user and vice versa. And this you have to do
every time a user-level process makes a system
call. You have to go through the kernel.
That's the border crossing cost. So that is
the first explicit cost that can be a
strike against microkernel if this were to happen too often. The second
strike against a microkernel based design is address space
switches. With the assumption that each system service is living in
its own hardware address space, whenever an application needs
any system service, that may involve the
servers living above the microkernel having to talk
to one another in order to provide that
particular service that was requested by the application.
And I mentioned that protected procedure call is
the basis for cross protection domain calls. So
here's the protection domain, a file system. Here
is another protection domain, the storage module. And,
if the file system has to get some service
out of the storage module in order to serve the original request from the
application process, that communication is implemented as a protected
procedure call. And going across hardware address spaces minimally
involves flushing the TLB of the processor in
order to make room for the TLB entries of the domain
that we're entering. And we'll talk about that in a little bit more detail
shortly. But the key point is, there's an explicit cost involved in going from
one address space to another address space, and that is the second strike
against a microkernel based design. The third strike against
microkernel-based design is the cost for doing
thread switches. These thread switches have to be mediated by the kernel. If the
file system needs to make a protected
procedure call to the storage module, in order
to complete an application level request for
an operating system service, that involves the file
system having to be mediated through the
microkernel in order to go and execute some
functionality in the storage module. So that
involves a thread switch, and IPC, in order
to do that. So in other words, the basis for protected procedure call is thread
switches and interprocess communication, which has to
be mediated through the kernel. And this kernel
mediation can be expensive, that is, thread switches
and interprocess communication can be expensive. That's the
third strike against a microkernel. So all of these three strikes that I
mentioned are explicit costs associated with
providing an application level service in a
microkernel based operating system, because the
application has to first make a request
to the micro kernel. Microkernel may have to pass that request on to server
processes that are living above the microkernel, and
the server processes may have to talk to
one another. And this protected procedure call itself
has to be mediated by the microkernel via
thread switching and interprocess communication. And in addition
to all of these explicit costs, there could
be a fourth cost, which is the implicit cost. And this is due to the memory
subsystem and the loss of locality that
can happen when we are going across address
spaces. And when the file system makes
a protected procedure call into the storage module,
at that point, we are changing locality
from the address space of the file system
to the address space of the storage module.
And therefore, the thread that starts executing inside
the storage module may not find the cache warm, meaning, the contents of the
cache may not be reflecting the working set of the storage module that needs to
get executed right now in order to satisfy the request coming from the file
server. And this loss of locality can
be both for address translation in the TLB,
for this new address space that we are
in, as well as for data and instructions that
are contained in the cache. Both of those may
take a hit because of the fact that we're
going from one address space to another address
space. That's the implicit cost of the locality loss
that would be the fourth strike against a microkernel-based
design. All of these strikes against a microkernel-based design,
seems pretty solid. Now how does L3 go about
debunking, the myths about microkernel-based
design. Let's see that, systematically.